College then you can do what you want a
source tells ET that Laurie locklins
relationship with her daughter Olivia
Jade has improved since the College
Admissions scandal garnered national
media attention so I want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that a 54 year old actress
and her fashion designer husband Massimo
Jian uli have been accused of paying
$500,000 to get their daughters into
college at the University of Southern
California I don't really care about
school as you guys all know they have
since pleaded not guilty to all charges
scandalous mother back in May a source
told ET quote olivia is having a very
hard time dealing with this and for the
most part she's cut herself off from her
mother and is going out and partying a
lot though a more recent source claims
things are on the mend quote Laurie
knows they will all grow and learn the
source also says that the fuller house
star is getting back to her day to day
routine quote the drama seems to have
died down since the initial shock we're
just a nice normal family you know like
we don't we don't have anything
outrageous really happening and a second
source adds that time is helping to heal
everybody makes mistakes B no parent is
perfect
you